we will now present an Oscar to one of  the talented ladies nominated for Best  Performance by an actress the nominees  are gene Simmons in the happy ending  Maggie Smith in the prime of Miss Jean  Brodie Liza Minnelli in the sterile  cuckoo janvier Abu Joe in pan of the  thousand days and Jane Fonda and they  shoot horses don't they and inside is  one of five beautiful performances the  names is Maggie Smith in the  when I'm standing here and I'm thinking  that that with a marvelous husband like  Robert Stevens and a distinguished  director like Robert fryer and the  courage of a man like Richard zanuck  well put those all together and you just  can't miss and and they didn't and we in  America present this award to you Maggie  asthma and with as much thanks as it is  a tribute to your magnificent  performance and thank you everyone from  Maggie Smith